doing this Brendon let's do it how do it
right do it right
hey hey you gotta quit sending me those
pictures from that artist of the now I
have a he's a amazing artist Photoshop
sieve made us very funny
that cracked me up you breathe keep
sending pictures of those items and no
it's an algorithm I don't know what's
going on Rogan I on the group thread a
picture three gay men went hey bro hey
brothers yeah I said hey brother yes
brother this is us just us three guys
hanging out what's the big deal
hey brothers hey brothers it's so dumb
that I say Abraham Tom hey brother see
you're doing that with J and I we're on
the road hey brothers don't fight
brothers I was laughing so all your
friends brought brothers brothers I was
laughing sword when he said oh you know
that pictures gave me wit hey brothers
this could be us let's all live together
so ridiculous it's so stupid it's so
silly took my wife last night I don't
like myself that much she got teary
she got teary she got teary about it I
go what do you shouldn't spaghetti like
you know what I hate my oh you know you
know my mother-in-law who I love so much
man she said she goes well I mean I'm
Anna needs an oxygen tank around Brian
because apparently I suck all the oxygen
I was like that's a terrible thing to
mess and my wife cuz I always thought
you loved yourself like beyond anything
I go I why I hate myself on this Stern
the therapy is over dinner what's going
on it was dinner and then we had couples
therapy and she was like he said he
hates himself and I was like but I'm a
comic did you Jer did you just pull that
card out to save some ground like we're
things going back I've done that before
I don't like myself I'm afraid to her
what haha oh my friend does that my
friend has a hit when he's devold
emergency bridge he's divorced but his
wife was a nightmare and a [ __ ]
nightmare to the point where they they
started fighting and they were fighting
in therapy and ten minutes in the
therapist goes okay okay okay
a long time this is not new you guys
should get divorced oh wow that's it she
said what a nice day ok ok ok
like that you usually honey deke and
drag you along on saying $200 she goes
you guys are you guys are absolutely not
Matt ten minutes he got divorce but he
used to just when they said she hate
they fight she'd be freaking out does he
travel a lot so he'd go uh and he
grabbed his heart and she got what my
heart my alright I can't breathe okay
she would immediately go I thought the
diversion yeah I do it myself
yeah that's another girl bed play dead
just have the old possum did you ever
see this new on pause so my just if this
dude got caught cheating on his wife
Honus girl this dude in any and he she
caught him in a car with him she goes
you [ __ ]
and they had it on tape was called
cheaters remember that show do you golf
do I ever right staff he got stabbed I
got stabbed that [ __ ] staff look
you're right he's old Altman snitch did
you did and I had a problem with this
guy me too meanwhile had a problem wow
the [ __ ] jumps out of the car
runs and climbs a tree and he won't get
out and his girls like he's only did the
old caching treaty she [ __ ] treat him
he did the old cabinetry it was a lame
tree it wasn't that high but he was just
stuff like when those basic trees in the
part like like LeBron James ketchup and
drop his ankle no problem right so he's
up there like this and he's like he's
like sitting there and she goes she's
like Chris calm down calm down and he's
like he won't say [ __ ] he's just hiding
up there like this in she goes what are
you doing man don't just set up that's
rings and he wouldn't say anything just
call mm-hmm and he wouldn't look at her
look at me and he's not looking at her
he's just staring at the wall that's not
a bad way he ran out of it-it's not a
bad you're you become a child
immediately
the car ran and jumped up with a hard-on
Ching can you bring that up when the guy
from cheese gets stabbed for [ __ ]
being a snitch its stabbed on a boat I'm
pretty sure yeah talk through the show
after that I know he got stabbed
yeah sure was
it was classic Fiona's name but he gots
I didn't like it because you never know
why somebody knows people can have
issues and it just adds ever bro Joey
get stamped yeah listen uh that's got
this guy's the host though right yeah
the host gets down okay okay
hey bro keep up real pop fly give me
what's he doing minutes
yeah fast word xx stab send the story up
I can't believe he's alive this no be
honest Bob pitches yeah get off his boat
I kind of understand boats and honestly
I understand it oh yeah one guy fell off
and when every time I bust I produced
the court both of those yeah Mitchell
well Mitchell stabbed him because you
guys vote the guy was surrounded by a
bunch of men that was that say he was
being threatened he's all I don't give a
[ __ ] I just stabbed the guy from
cheaters
that's the she by the way if you're
gonna do a show like that yet you're
gonna run a new home up that's what you
get you're gonna run into a [ __ ]
was trying to get a boat in a dicksuck
and you [ __ ] the game up got stabbed
goddamn he got stuck yeah I did
and I cancelled the [ __ ] a stomach
that's carrots here
he's fast he's try to keep it together
that's knife fights with all organic in
and [ __ ] apparently watch that if you
get stabbed you try to keep the knife in
your box when you let go yeah don't pull
it out keep it in your body even if you
get stabbed in the bacalao huh hold it
in your heart that's the old crocodile
Hunter's nowadays he got stabbed in the
heart with a stingray yeah and his
initial reaction was the pole had it
ripped a bigger hole Iraqi pit they said
he should have left a bit so rattling oh
[ __ ] well that's hard that's hard to
think of that yeah it's gonna be tough
because it hurts yeah say this why Joey
deserved this man yeah I did a VHS vh1
thing where they would have me comment
on videos and I got so riled up about
this and I said I think the guy kind of
deserved it I didn't I don't know if I
said that but I was like I'll say if
you're gonna do that to people you're
gonna get shot or stabbed so there's
gonna be some refuse ready dude you
don't take that [ __ ]
and then I adult I was never asked back
oh you're never asked back paddle tail
they like me a lot and then that was and
I got a little worked up about it I mean
of course that's gonna happen that's
yours I mean I hope that guy's okay I
don't want I don't want that guy Joey to
be hurt but I want him to recognize what
he's doing you know yeah yeah I mean I'm
sure he's okay did you check with his
doing chin might be is he kind of did
you see him do the the Andy Dick showed
you ever see Andy Dick's you ever see
Andy Dick's talk show no I know he
[ __ ] hilarious he did a talk show
where it would be the guests would be on
for one minute have you ever seen it no
it's [ __ ] funny man he did it in his
in his in his garage and and this guy
was a and this guy was like a yes and he
has a really long nose and he was behind
the curtain at all you could see was his
no sticking out it was so his nose was
too high they there was nowhere for him
instead they'd be behind a curtain
against a wall you just see his nose
sticking well to say he's doing chin
didn't say he's fine good guy
mr. Stovall I shouted or not at an Emmy
Awards for some reason well
Joey Greco he's probably flip king yeah
yes damn right I guess Ted yeah you got
stabbed I mean let's get high personally
if you want to do that show I would have
been like no I'm gonna get shot Bobby
absolutely not you dealing with passion
your passion love that's dangerous cops
I'll tell you get the [ __ ] away from
that it's a bad cops get hurt I wish
they'd bring that show so in 20 said
last year he hosted a parody of cheaters
on Netflix so there's a show on Netflix
called cheaters with a Z oh yeah yeah oh
man that's that's like it'd be funny of
that show and he gets killed every time
like Kenny and yeah that would be funny
dies different each time yeah yeah yeah
I think it's bit Colin skit it would ya
I don't know she just was good man
cheers Carrie is we've gotten older just
like me oh is when you know you're
getting older right when you see people
here it is it's the I'm Joey Greco and
welcome to another installment of
Netflix cheaters another stone
meet Jason Warner a part-time pool
cleaner these are parodies he's actually
a funny guys girl he's I think he's got
he's kind of a comedian looks password
for for hey bro your girl hardly pay for
this gap you [ __ ] on you trying to cover
your bases well cuz I then I saw I saw
him do Andy Dick and I was like oh this
guy gets it he's got a good lovin all
orange is the new black but then we
stole all the shows it's just it's not
real that's on Netflix
that's not made on Netflix look at
Netflix published it Wow
fifteen thousand views only well yes
trying you know uh-huh he's alive they
need to recreate that show but this day
and age is can be it's gonna be tough
yeah that's not a good show it's a
sticky show cuz you're gonna have a
situation no but what do we not all
right watch it there was another dude
who shot at the cameras I think they're
due to have guns man they pop guns and
there you be careful who you decide to
snitch John you certainly do would be
funny if there's a cheater show and they
just go for rich white businessmen
they're not gonna shoot you
yeah I don't like I don't like catching
people in situations where they're being
human because you never know what the
story is at their house and you don't
know if their children are gonna see it
you don't know how
I gotta deal with it I don't like ever
brother I don't like public shaming of
any kind like that I don't like it I
think it's not good it's better wait I
would watch the [ __ ] out of it it's so
bad I don't like watching people's
demise publicly a paintball gun yeah hey
with the paintball yeah yeah there's a
shooting with paintball sure some of it
was scripted for sure five facts you may
not know about cheaters please click on
that to me it's not all fake I was so
broken hard when I found out Jerry
Springer's fake you know what's fake all
that dough
yeah is all staged it was all staged all
of it Jerry Springer
no ya lot enough all of them were but a
lot of them had the state actors but
they had writers a thing they even had
people talking about how they went
through rehearsal and all this stuff you
know they they're pretty poor they need
money so they just took the money didn't
acted it out we mean they people that
are on ik so they would come out so they
we come out age come out and just start
fighting well they would come up with a
platform B I can't do this do this
that's why can you see him punching they
kind of like hold by it bro you serious
awesome you thought it was real yeah
that was really better than that was
real cuz I saw his girl start to cry and
I was like oh no actors humiliated you
know I don't like humility I don't like
public humiliation I hate it I don't
think public humiliation in any way
shape or form is good I got why I never
liked any anything I don't that's not my
humor so it would say what's the what's
the first one he wasn't the original
host
Tommy grand was do you guys know who
Tommy grand is [ __ ] don't what else sure
I was likely staged more than it was
real Oh bother
what else so a mixture of fact and huh
is also totally staged that is mother
trucker okay mmm it says sure it would
have been totally great if Greco had
actually been stabbed so we could freely
appreciate this stoicism and that's the
directors interested hold off sir
totally great if Gregor actually been
stabbed you know what if he looked like
he was fake I agree so we could fully
appreciate his sources in the after Matt
Inside Edition later did some poking
around and found that no arrests match
in the description of the attacker
made by Texas police department
additionally douzo tell researchers
claims that she had been paid 350 RS for
her involvement in episode as the other
woman you [ __ ]
hi you bastards man I thought that [ __ ]
was real that was very good listen they
got me they got me well here's the same
guy that J spring has been well sure was
I'm an older I'm an older busting man I
apologize his older gay trust me I'm an
older gay trusting man like what what do
you say I said I'm an older trusting man
you said gay I said older trusting I
don't know what you told her just like
that back well [ __ ] you dude that's such
a bummer but remember how big of a deal
Jerry Springer was when it was happening
I rush home from school I saw him at a
bar mom oh no I'm in fact Mondrian you
know the sky bar and he's just hanging
out some girls older guy and then
somebody I knew knew him started talking
to him nice guy he was the mayor I guess
it wasn't in the mayor of Chicago for a
while or something like that yeah I he
did was he what he was in politics yeah
yeah after the show
no before believe he's the mayor anyway
it was just interesting he to meet how
does that man not have a lawsuit that me
to me again it was probably a look at
him here's a lawyer - Wow
yeah oh he did buetergerds bringer
podcast
everyone has podcast now even the rock
rock has his own yeah damn or he does a
weekly one or something that's cool The
Voice to the people yes it's what did
say he does now a [ __ ] never mind let's
see now a political career he's a big
deal you didn't still on TV oh really
yeah you know who I saw was uh
Romare uh Ben Stein yeah he's a
brilliant man
he's writer for Nixon he's a brilliant
British speechwriter for Nixon I saw him
I was eating sushi and he was there and
he I guess he goes to the same place
every day and she was do usually yes
he's old as balls old but Ben Stein was
a political like a deep political
thinker remember him on win Ben Stein's
money or also obviously
you guys are known from bueller bueller
amazing actor and then also yeah he's a
rider and then he now he can choose to
CNN that's he
yeah political stuff smart guy very
smart and he's also a professor at a
college if you really yeah Ben Stein
he's had a really interesting career
that's just [ __ ] really interesting
career right like his ears are bigger
than both of us put together it's got
some big ears uh a burger he ate the
[ __ ] of this sushi he did hate this big
sausage dick fingers and would grab the
little yeah little area just do were
curious smart guy
there is Ben Stein it's Ben Stein
remember that show Ben Stein Jimmy
Kimmel yeah bear that yeah what was the
man show right there answer the man show
with Jimmy Kimmel was like the this the
side chick and yep he's just witty and
now he's frequently that he's Jimmy
Kimmel yeah Jimmy Kimmel's great amazing
I love that guy they didn't let him
loose on the Oscars which is
disappointing but whatever you know not
in today's world no as a bummer you know
one day bad things but he was a great
powerful now not us Brian his mother was
afraid we're not we're not sir
we do our thing we speak our mind yeah
we can trouble sometimes a little bit
who makes the shoes bro these are greats
bro alright don't be mad you know you
know great and they did ask for my
permission and I granted him your
permission they open a storefront on a
bikini I know that and did you get I
didn't really sign the waiver but I
suppose I'll let it slide I told them I
went you know what Brian's out of town
right now but you do have my blessing
there's an Adidas store grace is a
smaller company so it's okay
but they are right before Saltonstall
ice cream which I did go to yesterday
and strolled the streets we Brennan and
I will were strolling a bikini as we do
we'll talk to each other in nice good
and then we'll go should we get at least
a child scoop and then you go well we've
earned it like oh we have haven't we
because we were just hanging out and
then we go and eat it and then we go
and then I always go I shouldn't have
eaten that not me I don't I wish I had
another scoop yep you you exercise good
restraint you get a tiny little scoop it
just depends you date are you dieting
right now are you good you look big big
arms like thick you look thick I've been
eat whatever I want lately yeah you got
your big boy I'm going through the move
up my show legs are huge this looks like
a big boy thick I'm thick yeah I I mean
still working out all the time but yeah
I decided to go off the diet because I
get a start back on keto on Monday yeah
you have tequila box coming out with on
it got all that so you could get back in
Quito that's right so I've been for what
I before I go on a strict diet eat what
ever I want yeah so like when I was in
New York
everyone's like here you try our choke
delicious yeah I had eight slices into 8
slices in two days I post mice that your
body carries it well you're just a big
boy thick just a thick Samoan nuts the
Mon bro you're a Samoan guy nothing
you're basically a Samoan right
no would you to admit that you look you
look you are a Samoan man I'm not a
small man well what I mean is that
you're a Samoan that's what I mean like
there's no difference Oh either Samoa
you don't know what they're like you're
you're about as strong as the average
Samoan in the Pacific
that was a guy wish unless thick yeah
I'm not as thick son dude how about this
is ridiculous - my dad's in town right
because we're moving
and my dad's when he was last time I was
here I like to beginner that show The
Bachelor just a beginning what's a train
wreck and they're meeting the people I
say I don't like all this stuff
in-between I just like the beginning
when the girls are trying to make their
introductions in the Roses I like that
[ __ ] show yeah so my dad and stepmom
were there that night we don't want to
watch this then they watched it right I
fell in love with it okay I haven't seen
it since when that comes last night
last night's the finale have you heard
what this dude did no so you know how
they they pick they have to pick between
the all the girls I'm not mad at those
girls why would you be there's no reason
to be upset so it goes that's the whole
color code there too but no asian girls
these are problem agents well you
there's always the token black people
because they'd only it sued and
they slowly cut them as the years go by
yeah show goes bad that Ranger which
they should make way way before you say
anything I'm going to tell you who he
chose hold on come on bro all right you
ready see the girl right next to his
left
yeah that makes me picked her that makes
sense and see the girl see the girl next
to the short hair little pixie girl up
top left yeah girl next her yeah so
check it out so he proposed to the girl
the brunette the top left seconds left
he proposed for his turn that's the show
okay they've made it show for three
weeks ha ha so he proposed to her so
then the show stops right you're not in
Peru you're not in Italy you're not in
French not Prague anymore you back at
its crib you in real life I'm a fun guys
to work so then you get to know each
other three weeks ago his by he goes oh
[ __ ] I made a mistake I think he slept
with her realize she's terrible in bed
was I saying that why so then he goes
her goes hey listen this isn't working
out I'm actually can't stop think about
the other girl breaks up with her and
then goes to the blonde chick goes hey I
know I didn't pick you but I can't stop
thinking about you let's do this propose
to her
so everyone cannot stand and he did it
on TV yes it was awkward to watch I'm
sure that was scripted - wasn't it - no
I'm saying well they said well so using
Jake's ringers Robo you're saying this
is good the thing is it was things on
for the first time this is their whole
pitch it's a it was on edited to see the
emotion it looked pretty [ __ ] real I
don't think these girls that good I like
it I like the darker ones that one the
dark ones now because she had her heart
broke isn't the new bachelorette
yeah you could win that bro so someone
passed the age gap but man that boy that
would go up one chin that black girl
right there that's she's yeah that's my
boy 1 yeah I agree she's a good and then
go up chin to the last row go all the
way over over over the right low no keep
gone right and then that there's my girl
right there she from India uh I doubt it
this is a lakh and why don't you two
kids well that's probably person bright
familiar yes Persian you see the little
the little the girl who looks like the
Disney Tinkerbell far left yep she won
the show we happy with a little facts
about the show why I know all this about
that rich cuz gay man so gay man a man
came in so she's 21
she's 21 years old too young for me to
wait to eat well take it easy yeah me
too
so she's 21 when you talk when you go on
the show you're gone for a long time
right and you don't have stacks of cell
phones anything she didn't tell her mom
her mom thought she was missing he's the
one that she reported missing that's her
and she she got done with the shows like
mom I told you I was busy doing
something but there was police looking
for and I finally realize she's on the
show that's crazy so the contestants the
girls they don't make they don't get
paid at all so a lot I'm going to Det
trying to cuz you got there's no
wardrobe either oh you want to look good
all the time so she make far in the show
so they pay for your traveling your
house your food all that well you're a
contestant on there but for your
wardrobe so I'm going to debt and on
lose their jobs
oh no and the other so and then homeboy
in the middle they get the man who I
think is clearly gay which I have no
issue with that all but it's clear as
day the man is homeless sex is that
right it's so clear he gets paid you
usually make like on the minimum about a
hundred thousand to be a guy the host
I think he's clearly gay so my dad's
super into the show my dad falls asleep
like dads do and he was waiting for the
finale and I looked at John which is no
I knew it he came out as gay my dad goes
what what oh my I want dad he's a gay
man I told you because we made a bet
he's a gay man he just broke up the
other girl says he's actually in love
with John great one of the sound guys he
goes no [ __ ] way
yeah dad he goes this is unbelievable
this is unbelievable video it hey dad
made all that up because what's wrong
with you I went I thought it's hilarious
can you fell asleep girls you got
problems and did talk to me for learning
you and I have a mutual friend
a mutual friend that we
know very well whose dad was caught by
his mom getting [ __ ] he was in his
grooms outfit he not tell Dawei the unit
the wedding he was in his groom outfit
and he was getting [ __ ] in a bathroom
by a guy from the wedding ok is this
recently I say [ __ ] that mean he was
getting his rump destroyed by another
dude
and she went oh god they stayed married
hold on no hold on you know I'm talking
about oh I don't back the truck up hold
on okay
I thought the gentleman I'm referring to
yeah I thought it was his dad in the
junkyard was getting sucked off by grown
men yes and his dad same guy that's
right the day of the wedding there's
recent mom which is kind of recent no
this is this is when before he was born
oh oh oh his dad oh who died
unfortunately of AIDS when who's 21 21
yeah Wow yeah so during the wedding day
they're gonna get married she opens up
the door he's just yeah I'll go with you
on it mom was okay yes you see out there
yeah see out there good talk and he
tells that story and it's just your did
you draw dropping you're just like does
he do it on slash his name out because I
don't think I heard it he may have
talked about it on the table so we're
all good yeah we're good but you know
I'll let him tell me sorry it's better
if he's a great story Wow that'd be
tough yeah man and I talked to her about
it talked to his mom about it and she
said yeah I used to drive him sometimes
too he had this strange sexuality and
I'd sometimes I'd drive him to his you
know flings and there's the Loyalists
damn chick she just was being liberal
and she was I just loved them too yeah
it's cool if you wanna live there
everybody loved him he was a [ __ ] deny
the 21 of AIDS yeah yeah well no he
dieded
when when all my friends went are from
all kid and he died of AIDS yeah
yeah man Oh late 80s heard well yeah we
have another mutual friend where her dad
when she was like 17 was like oh I'm gay
yeah without she leaving this family and
gonna move in with my boyfriend yep
Brian yep think you're crazy that would
be it happens all the time not all the
times it happens I know somebody else is
who had that happened to him and in fact
in fact his mom and dad are both gay and
always were gay and they were both opera
singers and they just did it - yeah and
I think he's very public about that -
but but they they uh they just when he
was 20 or something they were like we're
gay see ya and they both moved in with
somebody of the same sex plus they're
happy I guess you'd be pretty
open-minded though I'm pretty
open-minded that stuff like I've had mmm
like I've had like transsexuals
something like that reach out to me or
when I'm in New York I saw what and I I
had no idea I don't care I don't have a
problem with that all I don't judge it
also my gorgeous - they've reached out
to you for what it was just saying like
what's up testing the waters oh and I
sent him you're like gay man no no let's
let's stay with you for a second how can
be comfortable with us sit in these
waters for a sec who's gonna be a little
hot so no be comfortable it's my
waistline
you brought this up well I'm just saying
how it's story see what I'm saying well
what do you want
I've had a couple of guys to it I don't
judge it all the transsexual and now
women and they've reached out to me and
you know it's like it stops there what
I'm saying is I'm very oh you didn't say
it's no I don't know what I don't judge
you're saying it stops there now I - I
said my Chin's way any murder
you left a very oh you left nice new
house and he murders well he takes them
into his basement but fight it up is I'm
very abdominal but I don't judge you I'm
very open-minded no I mean and if they
come to your hotel room and um it's fine
Oh God
that's all I'm saying you're big well
you know you've got big hands but you're
pretty don't know how the conversation
happens that dick is a problem yeah just
move the old dog the nuts in the back
well now we're talking now we're talking
strap that thing to your leg and we're
talking like out machete yep I get a
push
let's let a man take my tears wash it to
the side you got your piss our and we'll
leave you with that of course you got a
piss or do you have to go do you have a
little pressure built up Rogen's bumping
trunks me and me and Jamie who were
talking Jay and I go bro did you see
that black China porno and run goes
what's wrong with you guys man why would
you watch that [ __ ] on it ah I'm trying
to jack off Rogen they're probably
jacking off Rogen is so much more mature
than we are I feel like now yeah you see
such an animal he's like I don't know
alright so why would you look at that
like ah cuz its blac chyna with a fat
ass it's kind of jack off why not try he
was something wrong with you guys my
feel judged right now but Jimmy Burke
says stuff like like look with the way
he like emphasize stuff they'll talk and
he's like and I was I was tired I jerked
off I put on like dude
I jerked off I came and I went to bed
and you're like dude can you not use
that resize you know like he said I had
to either piss a pista pissed and then
then we [ __ ] like a god can you
[ __ ] take well that we joke around
talking all the time but sometimes when
you bring that same vernacular that same
tone of voice like my dad's in town
right and my dad was talking referring
to Johanna and everyone in her mom how
they're like boxing stuff up and my
dad's like they they there's they I mean
she has a work ethic and I went Mexicans
dad they're Mexican you know I'll see
Joey Joey yeah you you need to be
careful to talk like yeah why they
protected myself I know man
they work hard I leap this hard
it's buddy I'm gonna take it I'll take
over from here okay I'm gonna keep going
chin and I'll have a little conversation
go for it go pee / yank there you go
go pull on it pull down pull hard pull
American gin
yes what are we gonna talk about that
bullets god I was gonna have a black
China pictures I just randomly brought
them up earlier let me see some
blackjack well show it to Brenda when
he's here to see what we're dealing with
so attractive at all mainly because I
think she seems like a bad gal that's
partly a part of it she seems mean I
don't I don't like I don't mind like a
mean person actually the last thing that
happened to her whatever it was her
boyfriend the Kardashian guy he's the
one that was well first of all she
cheated on him a lot which was nice to
me but then he's a face right no she oh
yeah he she did that she did that by do
you feel like we're living in a mean
time like a mean culture 100% since
social media kawaii it really brings out
the dark side of human beings yep
it just it's like and people are like um
they do some awful things to each other
it's public shaming like just you know
like like if somebody that something
said something about somebody it could
be a political thing and then the other
side the trolls on the other side are
are just like sending the worst most
harassing messages they swap them they
they say BAE there's a gun there there's
a standoff and you got a SWAT team
outside your house and someone died
recently because of it yeah man let me
see some pictures of this black guy I
look at her body it's it's ridiculous
yeah but this isn't this isn't this a
fake but oh yeah look at look at that's
not for me dude look at this all I see
is a crazy person yeah that is just
I literally just see an insane human
being I'm like well this is what human
beings do
you're this crazy it's it's not gonna
end well
right I've always thought about things
that like I got life is [ __ ] long
people tell you life is short take it
from the 51 year old it's long you make
these choices and you're like I don't
know you can have a fake ass the rest
you are
wife gee-whiz black Chinese got a fake
butt huh look at that ass Brennan it's a
fake rumpy-pumpy nothing's real man is
it real nice if you can touch it it's
real right yeah it's a little too much
junk in the trunk your legs gotta be fun
for a ride her hair's obviously the face
thing on that body but uh that's a lot
of work ha when you wake up in the
morning you're not you're not you're not
getting water can't get not touching
that ass no you're not I'm not into it I
don't find her attractive
look at her hair can you only don't look
how it comes out like well I can just
see an implant in the body that's a very
weird thing to have to change had way
too much work now would I kick her out
of bed for eating chicken wings no can
we see what she looks like before all
this is there any picture of her with no
makeup
I see damage when I see that is that is
that wrong I see damn weird I'm
attracted to it no it's not actually
it's it's it's like being attracted to a
sports car or something you know what
I'm saying she's like she's so shoot
they're beautiful men she's so cute
she's real beautiful there Oh oh wow
she's sexy on the left way sexier see
don't you um you like a little bit more
you don't know she's no she's had way
too much work
oh yeah way too much work what's good
the problem when you have that much work
done on your face those fillers and the
cheekbones of Jesus Christ and all that
stuff it jesus H Christ Jesus
H eat me just how much he changed he's a
little kid there yeah it shows how much
she's changed with the promise when you
do those fillers on your face you tend
to look like you're gonna start to look
the same
yeah that's a good point that's true
here everybody's look at this mister
steal yo girl now she was a stripper
okay she's a terrible pot there yeah
that but that that's a dust when I got
faith it's a dumper that's a better fake
bug critter that's [ __ ] or on her [ __ ]
if she went from being a beautiful black
woman to what looks like an Asian it's
sort of a lot of Asian in there now see
I think she's gorgeous there yeah she's
yeah that's her that's a beautiful black
when that when they put too much fillers
in an ass it's not good man man I don't
get it I
like it I just don't she's short to
super show us a tough one sometimes when
you go Hollywood like that man you can't
stop it's an addiction Kanye West mom
died from there's a lot of it's
comparing yourself a lot of its that
comparison right now it's just being
never been happy with yourself in the
mirror like you hate yourself yeah I'm
surprised you worked on your faith well
wait what are you saying are you saying
idea I need work on my just say a couple
Botox shots and those ring yeah I don't
know man
I'm gonna tighten that self whoa now do
you not like that Brian
now is that too much for you Anna that
I'm a fan of that I'll be honest with
you if that's what she's wearing around
it's very hard not to wanna at least you
know help her into that car figure it
out it let me help you into that let's
figure it out yeah now it's gonna let's
let's because you got to duck your head
cuz that's you know Bend oh hello Ryder
so you hand over let me help you into
that car I'm gonna put your seat belt on
she's a ton of work done man does that
do anything for each in or no just you
like natural white guys he likes I mean
shake ice crowbar her her but there
doesn't look as fake as it does now how
would you put salt and pepper on that or
would you just eat it would you marinate
that in teriyaki chin or when you when
you eat people what are you do you
prefer the seared or barbecued busy rose
it just the plan either bloom on skewers
you just dig straight like a sausage how
did you drink the body of blood first or
how does it work I like to eat blood
good yeah yeah like coagulated blood
pig's blood have you guys I haven't but
I'm definitely not gonna come to your
home go to dim sum may they have blood
there it's great they have polite and
tripe together
like what that stripe is the stomach
lining he also eats so he also it's
sushi from 7-eleven so know what I'm
dealing with there no ice on the Ralph's
man what routes all the same [ __ ] yeah I
I can't do any of that stuff
now Yolo Wow so you'll eat blood
coagulated blood I can never do that I
did drink blood from a deer after it was
shot and my friend go took some vodka
and drained the blood from the deer from
its neck and I we said a Native American
prayer and drank the blood
did you cast the spell after that what
do you want no we're trying to be Gruen
a cult of this witchcraft okay that
makes let me tell you the story is this
the plot of the movie would you
appreciate this the girl that I was with
was from she was Persian and she was
[ __ ] gorgeous and I was trying to
impress her she had the biggest she had
the biggest titties the biggest natural
tits seen in my life I would eat some
blood past 20 years old yeah we shot
that deer and she goes you guys gonna
drink the blood and I go yeah and I want
to impress her and I put some the guy
put some vodka and so it doesn't quack
away yeah drain the blood and we said in
the name of my girl but I drank it it
was on my mouth and she was such an
animal and I was just made a hat nope
didn't get laid nothing work you know
like it's disgusting cuz and I got wet
oh I've seen this I because I've seen
the movie the craft yeah and this is
weird [ __ ] I thought it was normal right
this was the test and you failed and I
failed now they're not gonna be putting
your date between these two titties now
I did get I did get I did have oral sex
I was I did receive oral sex my knees in
a cornfield later that night no for real
oh no she was a hillbilly she was a girl
she came from a long line of hillbillies
this isn't West Virginia now I'm not
gonna lie about that I don't remember
and I didn't care
ask me if she was good-looking
absolutely not absolutely not
hillbilly what's that why were you on
your knee feel because I have problems
and because I really would you just like
oh hey woody do it over everyone sure
and you're like what am i doing
it's late I'm drunk and here's yes full
mouth here's my dick and I'm on my knees
in a cornfield
America so yes I did
I did do that I did do that so the the
Persian the fact is I've had sex in a
since tin in a horse barn on hay in
England with a girl who had teeth
I'm really not exactly I've never seen
teeth like this in my life
I've never seen a fight in somebody's
mouth and I'm trying to be I'm trying to
be I'm trying to be nice I have never
seen teeth this sharp or this and this
disorganized in my in my entire life I
could hear them going get the [ __ ] out
of my way you got okay have you ever
seen did you meter if you ever Google
like what it looks like what a Japanese
subway looks like before they're getting
on the trains when they have rows in
touch for their teeth her teeth were
there her mouth was it was a subway was
to do sub like where a teeth black you
know they were just they were so sharp
and what women you want to she had to
have race Ani she had a great pot I can
put up with some bestie that they put it
down yeah it was it was actually
fantastic but just her teeth were just
at ten besides the teeth you know her
body was fantastic they did theirs
theorists it dead how old was she had a
lazy eye Oh fun well I don't care I
don't want to be mean I hate talking
about somebody's face in a bad way but
she was very lazy I with Tetris teeth it
was what it was brother don't call me
brother and they're brothers brothers
brothers you guys know what I'm talking
about brothers yeah how was that when
this went down like 48 I was like I was
51 years old I was last year now here's
the thing no I was I was I was probably
I was young I was thirty yeah I've had
some interesting experiences like that
but a good life huh yeah and I've and
I've enjoyed I've enjoyed every woman
yet with our ugly ones yeah well they
weren't conventionally attractive and I
I found something 150 attorney we're not
some of these women and most them it's
not what society would label as
attractive conventionally they were
there they were unconventionally pretty
which means they were conventionally
ugly as [ __ ] yeah that's not my joke
that salad
but yeah the Grateful type yeah but you
know yeah and sometimes there's a woman
there they're the the women that society
would deem ugly or you see them in there
they're dressed down and they're just
whatever and they're a waitress and then
there's something cool about them and
then you have sex with them it's still
better yeah I've had yep it's the best
sex you've ever had yeah or they take
their clothes off and you're like whoa
you've got a great body or sometimes
I've had situations and I know you've
been here where they look like 1 million
dollars in clothing I mean we were like
holy [ __ ] stop the presses this is worth
this is crazy and then it all comes off
and you go you are the master directors
croissant astros croissant tubes you'd
buy those glorious golden kisses Anse
then you done release one of the ends
ago percent that types of reasons for it
in the world you know and you're like
what you like a croissant roll you're a
magician and it's all that's come back
you liar just open a little bit of air
that thing just goes yep you're like
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is spanks
deserves a goddamn and I am weird that
dick come from you yeah all right I
guess my buns yeah why do you have a
hairy chest um
kill for Cinnabon right now I woke up
and drank too much coffee I was
depressed yesterday right I have never
seen you depressed
neither of I and my wife before you
couldn't but weird is before yet the
studio Rogan our time before we're
talking about depression people we know
what depression and I go man whatever it
is I don't have that gene map it put his
face so many times they've knocked me
happy yeah he was just cuz you're doing
well he is worried and I'm like I've
always been I've had some rough times
man I'm I'm a happy person I figure it
out he goes it's it's because you've
always been doing well though I'm like I
wouldn't say that Joe and I go you're
not depressed I don't yet I said no and
I said we're joined well you're killing
it you've always been killed for how
many years and you don't have any
depression is that's because we I found
something I like to do I'm like no one's
ever depressed I said you know he's not
never depressed cuz time up comment
and one in specific I don't talk about
on-air and I go I've never seen Brian
depressed it's so weird you say this so
I've never seen Brian depress I've seen
more flusters to like never depressed
now and Rome does it gets the press I
don't know
yeah he doesn't know he doesn't know I
was depressed for two hours yesterday
for what sometimes sometimes not just
down but over what but but when I say
sometimes understand it but sometimes I
mean never just yesterday I was down for
two hours this stuff
yeah and then I woke up and I was like I
was possible yeah yeah yeah some
business business stuff yeah because I I
don't like when things are out of my
control and I can't control it
correct and then yeah yeah and then I
get mad at myself for being depressed
because I have it's I have no right to
be mm I don't know that's not fair to do
yourself no I think it's no no no I
think it's fine to beat her sometimes I
hear you do you know I say tell me tell
me like this is how I was thinking about
yesterday I had this really interesting
thought about myself now before he says
we go I have everything and I'm blessed
and I have this house and there's great
kids stuff like that
that doesn't give that doesn't mean you
don't have a pass to be depressed great
because that's your life that you've
created yeah you know so sometimes
people go what do you have to be sad
about you have a beautiful kid you have
a home you have this podcast you have
stand-up you have a TV show it's like
you know I get all that man I can still
there's still pockets where I'm sad to
not solutely but what I was thinking
about this actually
I'm Hannah so like that that special
that you saw right and that that was
like that took about the showcase that
takes everything first remember when you
absolutely [ __ ] well I appreciate it
and you know what it's the it's like it
takes everything for me to do that right
like I I worked so hard at that right
and so so when you put your best effort
forward like I can honestly say they
like I can't do any better right now I
mean I so it's a work in progress but I
can't do any better than I did that but
that's the best I could
that's the best I can offer right and
when you put yourself out there and it's
that hard and and for whatever reason
one entity doesn't want it or they're
lukewarm on it okay it hurts that can
that can really [ __ ] hurt but more
importantly what I was thinking about
was this was
like so van Gogh when he used to paint
he used to paint frantically right and
the reason he would paint frantically is
because he'd go into depressions that
lasts three and four months yeah and
he'd be he couldn't get out of bed yeah
and he knew that when that hit he was
really done so when he'd come out of it
he wanted to do work before it hits me
again it was like almost like this demon
would come and go you got you know he's
coming back yeah
so for me my brain is I'm so a DD right
as you know yeah horribly I I mean I'm
sure I would have put on been put on
drugs as a kid I'm literally it's like
there's music going on in my head all
the time and I had 20 minutes of the day
sometimes thirty minutes of the day
where things calm down and I can write
and I can come up with something like
maybe maybe and by the way sometimes
it's two days of just a discotheque in
my head and I can't [ __ ] think yeah
great so well I know so when I get that
moment of silence and I come up with an
idea that's like I cling to that you put
it into my thing yeah and so it takes me
so long to write what you saw like it
takes and you have to keep coming back
to it but it's can't force it either is
it so you know what I'm saying so the
process of creation is is constantly
trying to get rid of distractions and
stay you know in that space and I don't
know how you feel all that personal -
it's personal so when someone goes I was
alright you'll hold on yeah what do you
mean oh sorry man [ __ ] you mean alright
yeah yeah I've seen what you guys put
out I see no else you've signed hold up
what do you mean alright what's all
right about that right that's what you
want to do that's right what do you mean
oh I did want to do that and I did bad I
want to say exactly what do you mean
what's just all right because this crowd
disagrees that's all right yes you not
see the standing ovations yes I mean oh
yeah how about [ __ ] you yes don't you
want this is the best I can do I just
get I did the best I can possibly do in
this moment and so yeah but it's weird
how those it's just vulnerable you just
feel vulnerable but it's worried about
those little things uh because I'm sure
you got nine great things that from
Network since two ago we loved it we
liked than the one shows it's all right
it sure that's the one that you focus
towards probably and and and yeah yeah
and and I guess everybody feels that way
you know and when you write a song it's
a vulnerable feeling because it's like
not you're not trying a beach okay
you're trying to be really good when you
write a script with anything when yeah
your show you're doing the best you
you're you're putting everything you can
into what it takes shitload so you know
and then people go oh this is gonna be
great there's this like hopefully I have
no idea man that this is what I got here
yeah and it's been well-received but of
course there's the nay sayers stuff like
that patty patty patty Jenkins when she
did Wonder Woman she was she was getting
like feedback on Twitter and answering
back and me and Lowe's gravy and Rogan
were like do not [ __ ] look don't read
it be sure to keep going yeah keep going
and and by the way you know what's that
great that great great quote by [ __ ]
Michelangelo criticized by creating just
criticized by creating keep creating you
know I asked Todd Phillips I go what
drives you it goes revenge [ __ ] these
[ __ ] where everybody tells me I can't
do it and nobody wanted to be in my
movie everybody told me it was never
gonna happen
[ __ ] them and that's what drive for it
that hangover see a bit of that I will
let you know what do you have that you I
have that yes because because when
people say you can't do something and
everybody does you know and it's a good
thing it's a good thing you know so I'm
not completely understood you do you're
just down about the whole point of the
bad man I drank some wine I talked to my
wife from hard I I didn't I didn't do
that I press your now you're seeing that
here the sick dick now my dad managed my
depressed it's small sure does the blood
flows like we don't need that right I
got no time where the end of my face yep
my dick so tiny ain't horny when when
I'm now minute yeah yeah o'clock grave
dick yep and you know when they say I
think when a man scores a big job or
makes more money his his wife he gets
laid faster than otherwise you know when
you're doing well in your life you dick
it's harder when you're not you just
you're not thinking that you don't feel
so dude would you talk your wife about
being depressed what that must be new
here
no she didn't know what she didn't
understand and realize that let's go hi
am not my biggest fan
she didn't realize that like she she
didn't realize that what drives me as a
profound dissatisfaction with who I am
correct that tribes me yeah and it never
and I said to where I go it's never
going to go away I'm never going
one day wake up and go I like know
everything about myself no this is who I
am and I've embraced it and it works for
me and you know we're always told you
have to like yourself and you know
there's a lot of advice that's true I
don't either I don't I I don't know
anybody I guarantee you this is the
thing everyone's dealing with their own
battles I guarantee the rock wakes up in
the morning we all look at the rock and
God he this is perfect disparate yet
look at his body I guarantee wake some
mortals [ __ ] I wish I didn't have to I
agree with God I wish I could change
this yeah I have to do this No oh my god
why would he be working out of 12:00 at
night
what DRI keeps him going I agree a
hundred percent you know you don't
produce on that level from a from a
position of comfort and total
fulfillment you're always dealing with a
deficit something that I don't think
anybody who again I don't think that's
that's a rare thing for people
everyone's do but I don't I don't know
too many people awake them like
everything's perfect I look great I like
the way my eyes droop down I like the
bags on my I like my tits are like my
ass the one other educated people I
knows about everything every biography
and studied all the great minds and all
the great people I said what's is there
a through line like is there one through
line a personality trait to all the guys
and and he's thought and he said I would
say the only thing I can come up with is
probably self-doubt I never read anybody
who was great you didn't have a great
deal of self-doubt [ __ ] yes yeah you
know so it's an interesting thing and
again it's it's a good place to come to
you to realize that you know you don't
have to [ __ ] necessarily love
yourself but it would bother me if that
stuff didn't piss you off you don't say
yeah sometimes I want something so bad I
will get so upset and I'll come down
like how are we gonna get there how are
we gonna get a guarantee to get there
yes and that's off how do we change our
approach how do we change our approach
is what the [ __ ] are you gonna do to get
there this is how we're gonna have to do
it because if you're like I don't care
about myself it ends up on Amazon if it
ends up on Hulu that's not a big deal
like they're in the wrong business
you're no little [ __ ] yeah
here's the other thing though the
Buddhists will tell you that desire is
this is the is the root of all suffering
and so meditation all is to get you out
of desire
boodles fat sanely fat why would you
listen to a cheese I mean I have a lot
to do and then I'll meditate when I'm
dying I mean I like the like you know I
like to visualize and breathe and
meditate someone do you do any
meditation uh I'm just you at Yoga well
but not you know yeah I I believe about
the the breathing techniques and stuff
where I go I'm stealing your mind if I'm
nervous so I'm like down up breathe
through it I find writing myself up
everyone has their own like to run I
like to run and that's formative you
still running yeah how far do you run I
just did four miles I used to you know
average like 12 to 16 miles a week and
your knees in your body can take it if
it's just it's just four to six anything
after that my left knees like uh-uh-uh
not hat MA I'm about to start on a on a
meal plan though I think I'm gonna do
this isn't an ad or camp can't pay
anything like that if you guys know some
good meal prep places let me know I was
gonna do uh I forget what it's called
really Kim the greenbags just because
i'm so all over and like it'd be it
because I don't Sun fairs what I did
there's some other ones like Fit foods
that fair unfair what I was fighting I'm
sure we come up with a deal how was the
food the food's amazing it's just if you
stick to it yeah you can get lean in in
shape all right I could use that because
I'm so inconsistent I'm so all over yes
I didn't eat [ __ ] until I was going to
do Rogan and I wouldn't got a burrito a
Pollock delicious [ __ ] out of it had
myself some pork some white rice and
some black beans ooh so wrapped up in a
burrito with some guacamole and some red
sauce that's some nice [ __ ] like that
kept that tide me over well and you know
all I ate yesterday until about C
o'clock at night was just a small bag of
Doritos that's it that's it that's all
you had all day so I had all day huh
yeah sometimes you're fast hard
I'm not wasn't trying to just moving
moving and shake it out that's why if I
have these meals can be easier I also
need to set up my new crib a place to
work out I know we've talked about I
looked at that peloton bike stuff like
that well Robin was gonna give you
a poem like yeah I think if to his wife
though I hit them up I'll figure it out
you were you were talking hard you
should just stolen that pelisson bike
yeah there's enough for me Jimmy's got
yeah Jim's enormous [ __ ] man
I did like 20 pull-ups I mean not in a
row then real you know shooting with his
bow and arrow that's stuff I'm gonna
stuff scares me why because it's a broad
head and I'll go through your body
straight bullseye every time I'm 45
years I used to that I can hit that with
some [ __ ] event yeah man enough about
archery enough about that's right you
good posture you know what I'm gonna
take you an ice cream coming after this
that is the sweetest thing but I've got
an audition yeah for Jim Carrey's new
show that he's starring in on Showtime
yeah the role is really funny at what
time it's for someone who's gay at what
times the addition to 40 buddy all right
I got time well see where we get out
yeah we're sure well what do you got kid
oh no I don't but this is a special one
I could do this Jim Carrey Jim Carrey
I'd like to work with Jim Carrey we're
trying to get Jim Carrey I must show ya
Showtime for this right yeah see how
that goes
it's awesome all right what do you got
you have you tried or seen that black
ice cream or were you guys talking about
that black ice cream black ice cream no
it's like a new thing that everyone's
trying now black guys black ice cream
anyway on to the creative it's just like
what flavor is it though wait let me
actually google the phrase you see it I
like a nice vanilla shake no racist I
like your life you've been at Jenny's
ice cream to me it's the best so this is
what it is how [ __ ] do it it's not
better than salt & straw but it's not
better you want to block your [ __ ]
mouth you watchin this place bro I'll
care Jeni's ice cream is amazing they're
they're they're intelidox the turtles
intelligentsia that's good to ecology
you know you know Jenny's dude sorry bro
of course off rose yeah I ordered to my
house all the time you do your songs
strong won't deliver so I like midnight
I hope you get to Charlotte if you had
Chinese chocolates my big truck lice
cream mint okay but but they have a
almond brittle that's delicious and
they're bumble berry one yeah
and then there's Presto's nice yeah salt
y'all shits on all of them hates a
strong Hall just has a it's just full of
Lucky Charms marshmallows with vanilla
black ice cream
it's made with activated charcoal that's
what makes it blotchy oh don't say gee
whiz
update whoo wait you can get that black
ice cream at the little juice place
right it says little damage in the
fashion district I see people walking by
with this really Matt yeah ice cream is
so goddamn good in it it is now I've
decided I want something I told you
since you're depressed I'll take get a
scoop thank you appreciate that you buy
ice cream in a dicksuck failed not for
me what did you say Jen if he smiled
immediate well right what do you got
the first one is John Jones it's a
theory by you know Victor Conti from
BALCO yeah he says his theory is that
John Jones was micro dosing on
testosterone and then one of those
testosterone like containers that was
holding the the testosterone was had
like residue of that other stuff to
Rayna ball so that's possibly why he had
trace amounts of it well that's just
theory it's possible I mean upset man
knows what he's doing it when it comes
to drugs and stuff you know Victor Conti
so it was a so guys microdose because
they can't test you in time it'd be a
system before you get the drug test
right random but I was like what didn't
ya
so that would have gone out but that's
her in a ball since it's long lasting I
guess that's the trace amounts were in a
system that's what his theory is that's
the new thing micro dosing you know the
only thing that would validate any of
that is you at that high of a level of
micro dosing his brothers are in the NFL
who have you know just saying that's the
way athletes get around this New Age
drug testers through microd nice things
there's maybe am I gonna shoot it down
but maybe so
so the testosterone would have been in a
vial that was that were like an older
stuff whatever the testosterone came
from that lab or whatever okay that
would have this happen
cuz we'll make steroids isn't exactly
the most yeah not using strict
procedures so interesting so like they
might make creatine like some creatine
have draw steroids over residue or you
know whatever it is you'd have to like
clean that bat with like some sort of
special acid so if they missed one of
the steps there could be trace of
whatever in there still definitely
conspiracy but yeah just as good as any
other one at the end of the day no one
knows but John Jones no one knows but
John what else yet Jim did you guys
already talked about canola testing you
guys didn't right no okay well there's
that
John I should probably prove he isn't a
cheater before
Gennady golovkin rematch shout to kevin
ohio lee he's great
i will say his body looks different then
it did now he's older but he does look
more muscular
there's no i think heavier this picture
strictly and he's also older those
picture I remember he loves picture he's
like 21 he's around 18 20 21
so even we've take picture yourself from
21 to 27 and 21 to 30 you know like
different so that's there are steroids
in professional sports set but also the
clenbuterol that he took it is found in
in meat there's brings eyes you have who
have been test positive and then they
look into the meat and it's a problem in
mexico and the beef so they're
definitely finding clenbuterol also
clenbuterol is really not something you
would take to gain size or anything like
that it speeds up your metabolism to and
for cutting weight okay and it was such
a small trace amount you're gonna do it
you're really not gonna take this it was
a tiny amount tiny person so and I can't
guarantee you guys this fight will go on
this will just be a really is that true
does okay what mission dad - exactly
they're crooked as [ __ ] okay there's too
much money on line for this rematch for
them to go small trace Columb utero
let's yank the fight now get the [ __ ]
out it okay
so Victor Conti you know how I said that
by John Jones he says about this that he
believes it is the tainted meat because
a lot of fighters got like what do you
call that exonerated exonerated or you
know the same thing we couldn't win a
lot of my tastes these tests are so
as their carbon dating they're using
it's like carbon reads so they're so
[ __ ] sensitive that you know you you
you're just you're trying to train and
eat you know what I think should happen
though is like this small amount of
clenbuterol come out I don't think
should be made public right they should
go to Cannella scam go what's going on
here yeah test them again if it's not
there but I wouldn't release this news
until we know the full story because it
damages the fight yes I told my brother
what else you get Jim well real quick
wouldn't if this came out and then he
they do fight wouldn't it be bigger
because it's more news now you're saying
this is just hype in the fight yeah this
climber it's the fight hurts hurts the
fight yeah
is that because my mom read just goes oh
[ __ ] canal's a steroid user she doesn't
go I'm beautiful small trace amounts it
was in the meat most general public goes
a [ __ ] of canals on stuff end of story
is that Richard Conte casual phone no
who is that can ravioli he looks a
little bit like John Luther who is care
entirely he's one of the top
Yahoo's how much does it ever may
forever just boxing when the head
writers brilliant man with us yet all
right a woman in a plane mid-flight
tried to open the cabin door and she was
screaming I am God I'd have to slap a
[ __ ] I wonder what happened people have
no idea what's going on with her and
there's no updates on what she was why
she was doing it but white woman this
year no you can you cannot get that door
open
that's a passenger not a security guy
what's he doing he's just yeah he
actually threw her to the side and held
her there trying to open the door yeah
she's crazy she having a panic attack
that I am got stuff a little crazy
whatever she is losing around so that
was mid flight from San Francisco to
Boise Idaho all damn that [ __ ] San
Francisco Boise but I don't fly that
high so I'd be fine yeah you know I
heard it's not like the movies wherever
we had sucked out
she might be what's that
I heard it's not like the movies where
you open a door and it really it sucked
out well they are you lose cabin
pressure right yeah it happens but you
also find yeah I don't know either
talking about my ass right now but I for
have for it it's not like Hollywood
where it's like yeah give me your hand
they take they open doors and planes
when you're when you're about to perish
correctly not as high as these planes
right yeah it's not as cold it's not as
either way though you're not getting
sucked out like the movie yeah I think
it's about 30 to 50 below when you're 30
feet up in the air they scented the
cabin pressure did some people to be
impossible to open it but I'm imagining
there's locks that you can't open it
right yeah there was an axe right yeah
there was an ex defensive end he's six
foot seven 290 pounds and he was having
a manic episode he tried to open the
door and he couldn't so and nobody knew
what to do with him so we're good yeah
yeah we could he's a giant what else
good to that guy that stole the Oscar
his name's Terry Bryant is officially
charged with grand felony yep so he
could if he's convicted he have like
three years in prison $20,000 just crazy
there's better ways to spend taxpayers
money he's just crazy
I got a slap on the wrist check out
Jerry had his a back story he's arrested
over seven times Oh kinda does that look
like the one who sucked your dick in the
cornfield no he looks like a rough fella
he's excited for what over seven times
it's
he looks for [ __ ] crazy theft assault
and criminal mischief a bad guy if I was
casting a bad guy he's got those
eyebrows that are spiked up but he got a
ticket into the Oscars kind of handsome
is it hard to get into the Oscars like
if you were casting like the evil ass
absolutely not no absolutely no what are
you sayin howdy he snuck in you know I
have no idea no they said he got actual
ticket I know it's a tough ticket to get
to my friend of a friend one man to take
it yeah because they to get invited to
the Governor's Ball which he was that
they cast that they it's months and
months and months out before it's a
variance that you think it's tough to
get caught if he if he got caught seven
times so think about how much he's done
exactly you know that's a good kiss the
word con I got this for music best music
he's a career criminal he's psycho yeah
well she's got a social character um
he's on the spectrum how about this
there's not a big one but the White
House wants to let cops law officials
have the right to shoot down drones I
mean you're gonna have to have a
conversation about this as some sort of
as drones get you know more
sophisticated as you're able to carry
explosives on a drone ups and stuff off
so if you PS can carry huge you know
devices what do you think the people
that want to hurt everyone are gonna be
able to drive so I think there has to be
some sort of regulation on drones 100% I
don't give a [ __ ] about my kid flying
his drone and you shooting it down yeah
I would yeah it's scary not to mention
the amount of spying you can do on
people for sure you know dude how about
my backyard about my maintenance guy
today salt just got the whole cockatiel
I got a shower I'm sitting there I'm
sorry my phone and I looked up he's
cutting the bushes yeah he saw the pipe
bro they were doing work on my [ __ ]
house and I'm talking about 15 men on my
roof and I I would get out of the shower
they could
see me I would get out of the shower and
I would not for a second over to cover
my dick up hey you [ __ ] guys that's
my house you look at my dick is shut up
and do my roof and it's fine because
we're all fine here let's just act like
don't feel looky-loo don't be don't be
lingering on my piece I was even
embarrassed I slept well you know what
you're welcome you like speak up yeah
here you go boy I'm a big guy with a
small piece so what it was it the hot
summer's day soak this in yeah drink it
in there it is shrinking sure I'm gonna
shop and you can just see the head sure
I'm a pointer but you know what no I
didn't take a cold shower why you asking
me that boy sure it looks like a giant
elephant I got a big [ __ ] personality
a big [ __ ] mouth and a [ __ ]
mushroom and a positive attitude
mushroom cap with a positive attitude
fellas how about you how about I make
you some lemonade and he'd come and run
a train I'm a grower not a shower all
right
good gin man you always have to bring it
down to some gang though you did that
man I've seen it dude saw my junk will
cut my bush oh barbarism yes shocks it
sounds man on trial what happened Texas
judge had ordered a you know their
bailiff would have just shocked a guy
who wasn't who was actually standing
trial just shock him to answer questions
wrapped around oh so he's like no no
comics yeah yeah all right I did he's
thousands of volts into his body hold on
first of all but in the case of Terry
Lemoine's the device was used as
punishment for refusing to answer judges
questions properly ders 2014 trial for
soliciting sexual performance from a 15
year old girl 15 old girl she's answered
but because of this because of the
shocks the the case is thrown out so
he's he's free to go now
Wow well because you're you're you're
listening a response with electricity
correct so somebody's gonna probably say
whatever you want them yes that doesn't
sound like it what Jonah yeah what a
dumb dumb frickin judge but the reason
why they threw it out is because the
constitutional right to stand trial and
interview witnesses that was taken up
because he was too afraid to stand trial
now because he do his shocks that
reason we don't do this that makes sense
that said you had to know that as a job
they don't supposed to do what I almost
feel like the judge was in on it
yeah the judge is too smart to know that
this one get thrown out yeah that that
that's this I smell a rat I also smell a
rat mm-hmm oh geez I just saw this right
now so I don't know much that's known
about it but in Illinois what do you
guys think about caretakers giving
little kids melatonin ah does melatonin
actually work is my first question in
the gummy bears profile and it's gummies
before naptime
so reading this should be arrested now
if they're popping kids with nyquil now
we got a problem
melatonin gummies I love them myself you
mean to I hope these critters relax yeah
I don't know I mean I I prefer you
didn't but I don't think they should go
to prison yeah so if it was your kids
you you wouldn't want them to what a
person I don't know if you want the I
can see parents saying I should have I
should decide whether a harder percent I
don't get my kid melatonin and not give
me a win I was giving my son thiamine
which is a green tea derivative that's
calming and I was like you know hey
you're my wife that's my kid you got to
check with me before you do we had a
fight about it well but dining is like
it's like basically green tree the green
tea it's apparently it's very safe okay
yeah she's done the research drinking
tonight her kid today yeah through the
day I mean there she tried it want a
couple times wasted time yeah yeah and I
was like Lucy keeps them busy yeah uh
you're always worried that anybody's
putting something in your kids other
person that's my son's mother and she's
done the research up the ass and so
she's not gonna do anything she's not a
big believer in drugs so it's not a drug
but you know yeah I can understand
parents go yeah skittish about it yeah
what are you giving my kids melatonin
gummies for I probably would forgive it
though you wouldn't want them arrested
but you want arrested but deathly attack
the parents for you don't like that yeah
what else you get all right I think this
is the last one
all right a cop and believe this is
Texas oh he pulled over this woman and
searched her for narcotics nuts to butts
searching her yeah the video is here
somewhere she she like really attractive
she was wearing like short short she's
cute and I'm sure the cop wanted her so
well the video somewhere anyways well I
was searching her right yeah he was
searching her and then he put his hands
in her like you know waist area yeah it
wasn't like too crazy but put it waist
area and then he talked her for a while
and then he said are you any narcotics
or do you take narcotics she said just
ambien he goes that's a narcotic but it
turns out it's not a narcotic okay it
isn't our carcasses considering our [ __ ]
they said on like the way it's listed it
wasn't officially a narcotic but anyways
three hours later here he pulled over
again so it's trying to this time the
microphone was off and then the woman
said that he was saying like oh we can't
keep meeting like this again again right
yeah and then so she felt like violated
but I'd honestly think he was just
trying to date her 100% but you can't do
that as a cop so she's suing him right
now
oh and probably not the best way to go
about if your top but it's also you know
not hurt but he was by the book with the
search there no that's also the only
thing he doesn't had a book so video
yeah I'll find it here cuz we bribed
judge this yeah no I'll see if he knows
he's being videotaped right yeah he
knows this this one he does for sure
good and fast forwarded there another
cop there - don't lie so she's wearing
short shorts and then now he's now he's
touching her waist
yeah that's cheap let's stand a
procedure though innit
I don't know right a little extreme cuz
he grabbed her titties no he says he's
doing that he's not even looking down
though oh here's a raging boner oh so
he's making her shake her bra out oh and
she has a little much a little much but
man oh this thing it was very quick
no this thing I don't know what standard
police procedure is here he's putting
his finger in front of our eyes to see
if she's on something but he does this
for a while that's none of that that's
very standard so said there's a way
there's a reason you do that the eyes
are
yups butter that's right but this goes
on for like I think two minutes yeah
buddy you never know what he's trying to
see might be you know there's this huh
this is fine because he's not touching
her here
I don't know I'm gonna shake her titties
that was little she's very attractive
bye you're getting behind her like that
I mean well it's a little extreme he's
awfully attractive yeah if I had to do
that I would probably be like hey just
so you know you know you're on video
camera I don't know
I'd pull her back so the video could see
what I was doing so you can see my hands
and I explained to her what I was doing
weird thinking pulled over it yeah you
know they use they use the back of their
hands the TSA does when they when they
touch that area yeah and they'll use the
back of their hands but if I'm a woman I
don't know this giant dude you know it's
gonna feel really uncomfortable over a
second time she want to shoot him just
for this he pulled over the second time
to hit on her
of course you're creeping on me then
yeah that's what he [ __ ] that's where
he [ __ ] he took his chance he
shouldn't lose his job no he didn't went
about a better way of doing it but I as
a cop you know it what are you gonna do
man yeah yeah I don't have to pull you
over for being sexy yeah yeah you know
she's adorable
all right what else you got you is that
it that was it
ba-ba-boom son there it is buddy there
it is pal
there it is my buddy there it is brother
at least Trump is raising tariffs on oh
yeah that's the most important it's the
most important thing do you know that
they they can't find one economist worth
his salt who agrees with this idea so do
you know how what you know what they're
doing
no all steel coming from Canada Mexico
and and China is being taxed so the
Helsley 25% so if it's $1,000 the
Chinese government has to pay $250 to
sell US Steel okay so it's a tax okay
that's pretty steep right yeah but what
the Chinese accountant will do that is
that they so so so then what happens is
they will charge consumers of this steel
we have a lot of additional funds 25 so
now people that buy steel from China
which is all our industries are gonna
spend it's gonna cost them 25 percent
more and then not make steel them well
then then they make products they make a
lot of products and steel with Chinese
steel in this country yes and then they
send it back overseas for people to
consume our products but that's made it
with Chinese steel so it's a very
strange idea and so Gary Cohen who's
this badass goldman sachs guy who was
his economic chief economic adviser a
just retired he was like [ __ ] this
doesn't make him out dance dude and so
he's got all these protectionist and
he's nationalists in office now and i
just don't i know a lot of smart bankers
and economists don't agree in my family
oh no they're all conservative
[ __ ] these guys are liberal
democrats either
what's his reasoning for doing it uh
it's a protectionist thing it's an idea
of like here's the other problem is like
the guys protecting steel and coal dad
those two things are the world is moving
away from those things right we're
moving to our tack and [ __ ] like that so
it's like you know okay there are
200,000 steel workers there about six
million people of reliant on steel and
you know it's a very strange skewed
thing but he's just not a very smooth
he's allowing his ideology and his
campaign promises to kind of get in the
way of logic and there are a lot of
[ __ ] smart people who are
conservatives they're not liberals who
are like dude not a good idea
tariffs don't you're getting into a
trade war creates a lot of bad feelings
so I don't know what can you do I don't
know figure it out yeah it's interesting
it's know we can do go see Bryan Callen
Huntsville yeah you can this weekend you
sons-of-bitches Thursday Friday Saturday
don't sleep speaking of walk run
get your [ __ ] tickets here done at
Huntsville dot stand up live.com
Huntsville that's head of live.com you
[ __ ] get to be tough to fly that
website by the way
April 12 13 14 I'm in West Palm Beach
goddamn it then April 19 20 21 I'm in
[ __ ] stand-up Boston is that what it
is I love it laughs Boston you bastards
get your tickets at e5k come next week
st. Patty's Day I'm at Oxnard Friday and
Saturday Oxnard levity live then after
that I just added a additional late show
in Tampa for shows all sold out Tampa
improv March 22nd we just add another
show so Tampa get on it that first year
sold-out Friday Saturday that be the
23rd 24th I'm at West Palm Beach improv
Sunday Orlando and then the following
week I'm in San Jose improv San Jose
improv four shows two on Friday two on
Saturday get tickets right now tik calm
for myself and Brian the kid Callen this
is the fire the kid we're out